after you've written f of x equals x
squared we're gonna think about this
parabola and also a family of functions
similar to it but before we do that the
thing we want to particularly be
interested in is what is the derivative
of this curve we introduce calculus
earlier in the year we developed first
principles and we learned a whole bunch
of rules and want to think about this in
a very visual way which is actually
calling back to you one of the very
first times I taught like I'm gonna say
this class even though there's like all
these extra people since then like all
the way back in jail Ock I gave you guys
some paper and we graphed derivatives
visually if that reads any bells
whatsoever okay
here's what I'd like you to help me
recall when we write a function in this
notation f of X how would we normally
write its derivative because we've got a
bunch of ways to do it strength F F dash
X very good so on your keyboard when you
go and type in an F and find there you
know that little apostrophe right you
can pop in where is it on mine
there no hold on why am I not getting
mine that's a bit funny on a second I'm
think I'm gonna have to type it like
this yeah we go I beg your pardon sorry
okay so this is the UM this is the - I'm
looking for I'm sorry that it looks
quite small you can hardly see it on
from where you're sitting to see there
but if you want on your keyboard I think
it's quite hard to dig up within the
desmos keyboard that's on the screen so
just hit the apostrophe where is it it's
like next to the next - it's split the
quick marks right on your keyboard right
so when you type in F dash X this is the
reason why I asked you to label this is
f of X it just sort of automatically
hands you the derivative which is kind
of nice right does that match with what
you expected by the way what wish
hopefully by now know that the
derivative of sorry the derivative of x
squared is can you tell me the function
it's 2x because you take that power down
reduce the power by 1 and have a look at
the blue graph does that look like 2x to
you it should write like one unit across
to the top one
to etc okay very good now what I'd like
us to do is up here with our original
function let's let's play around with it
for a second I'd like us to add on so
press Plus and then go back to that
alphabetical keyboard or just use your
normal keyboard and pick a letter I'm
gonna pick C for constant as you're
familiar with when you hand it a
pronumeral that's not X or Y and that
kind of thing it says hey do you want to
add a slider so you can muck around with
that and we do so I'm going to add that
slider in and if you want you can be
very lazy you can just hit play now you
can see what effect does it have on our
parabola this is doing what the parabola
it's going up and down we would call
this translation there's a shift a
vertical shift but importantly I want to
ask what's happening to the derivative
it remains state it's not going anywhere
is it because our derivative right our
derivative it just depends on how steep
or how shallow it is and when you change
the position the steepness or shadows
stays the same do you agree with that
everything's fine okay good I'm hit
pause so that's not so distracting let's
just leave that somewhere in the middle
okay very good now I do want us to
change things to go up here back into
the original function instead of
changing that plus C I'm go up into the
index into the power right carefully
subtract that your function disappears
because it's waiting for you to put a
number in and I'm going to let you
choose a number at this point you can
choose whatever you like but I'm gonna
put it in just for the sake of
simplicity three so there's my X cubed
graph it's a little bit raised up you
can see because of my plus C what is our
blue graph what does it look like that's
a parabola it's not just any prabal you
can probably tell me exactly what
parabola it is because you know how to
differentiate this right you've got
rules for it what's the derivative of x
cubed it's 3x squared very good and you
can by the way you can check that if you
like if your graph looks just like mine
if you go ahead and you put in 3x
squared lo and behold it matches up my
purple graph matches up exactly with my
blue graph so we can confirm that that's
very good and like I said you can make
that power whatever you like I don't
know if you put in three like I did
but you could put in four right it's
kind of like a parabola that needs to
lose a bit of weight because it seems
fat at the bottom and you've got its
derivative which in this case would be
for X cubes okay so far so good so what
are we looking at at the moment I've
been understanding these derivatives and
thinking about what they do in terms of
just visually right quick question by
just looking at this one that's on the
screen this is our original function the
red one okay can we make sense of why
this blue graph is what it is when the
derivative is down here it's negative
what does that tell you about the
original graph when the derivative is
negative what does that tell you it
tells you what do you see so the
gradient is named you're very good the
derivative function it tells you
gradient right in fact that's why we
call it the gradient function also and
that's why you can see it's dropping
like a rock you see it's got a
decreasing sort of gradient at this
point right and what about this spot
right here
what's that spot we have a name for this
kind of spot it's a corner we've got a
stationary point it's like the grass not
going up down it's not going up it's
just staying flat and you can tell me at
that spot look at the blue graph what's
the derivative at this spot it's the
blue graph is on zero the derivative is
not going up it's not going down and
then you can see as I go to the right
it's increasing okay